When I was in school some of my teachers
used an overhead projector for lessons.
You don't see them around very often anymore, in
fact I was pretty surprised that they are still
available to buy in some places. They were already
going out of fashion when I saw them back then
and they're quite a rarity now. But it's pretty
cool how it works, there's a very bright bulb
down in the base which reflects light out onto
this surface and then these light rays are
focused through a lens onto this mirror
and then reflected onto the wall behind me.
And I can share any information I want on here by
writing on these sort of plastic transparencies.
Now I'm talking softly in this video because I
want this video to fall into the category of ASMR.
Now this is a genre of video that's
becoming quite popular and if you
haven't already encountered ASMR videos,
well they have a few intended purposes;
one is to help people relax, another is
to help people sleep and everyone needs
sleep and relaxation at times so maybe that's
why you can understand it's quite popular.
There's another thing that can happen with asmr,
often when you're listening with headphones in
it can give you this slightly tingly feeling
in the back of your brain and so that's why
people like it too. Often these asmr videos are
really softly whispered but I'm doing mine more
soft spoken. One of the reasons for that is this
projector makes quite a lot of noise. There's a
fan in the bottom to keep everything cool and
I'm worried that if I whispered too softly
that perhaps you wouldn't be able to hear me very
well over the sound of the overhead projector.
I would like to quickly thank Fabulous for
sponsoring this video. Fabulous is a pretty
fitting sponsor for this video because they
also place a lot of importance on relaxation,
mindfulness and self-improvement. Fabulous is
the number one self-care app to help you build
better habits and achieve your goals. I think
all of us have experience with setting new year's
resolutions that get abandoned pretty quickly but
the best way to actually achieve your resolutions
is to break them down into tiny habits and the
Fabulous app can help you stick to them. It was
developed by behavioral scientists at Duke
University and contains guided journeys to
help you achieve your goals. I've been using
it to try and set up a morning routine that
gives me a bit of momentum for the rest of the
day which I find can make all the difference.
There's no shortcut to changing habits but
Fabulous offers a sustainable long-term
approach to change your life by building on
small successes. To start building your ideal
daily routine you can click on my link in the
description and the first 100 people to do so
will get 25% off a Fabulous subscription. So thank
you to Fabulous and let's get on with the math.
I have a plan for today to show you some math
questions using the overhead projector and for
it to be a relatively relaxing sort of math
lesson or overview. For some of you math might
induce a lot of anxiety but hopefully this can
be a way to boost your confidence or interest
just a little bit in, you know, quite a
relaxing setting. I've got exam questions
from Brazil, Turkey, Australia, India, the UK
and the USA (*only covered 3 in this video).
This video is going to be the opposite of
the speed run, I'm going to be going through
the problems quite slowly and in a way that I
can talk about some of the fundamental ideas
involved in the questions so that even if these
things are quite unfamiliar to you or it's been
a while since you did questions like these that
you will be able to follow along what's happening
and what some of those fundamental ideas are
behind it. A reason that I've picked exam
questions to go through is for me personally
I've always learned quite a lot from watching
problems get solved compared to, you know, just
reading about the fundamental ideas, seeing
them actually in action and used in a problem
helps me understand their context a lot better.
Our first stop is Turkey; this is
a question from the 2021 AYT exam
and like many of the questions
that I've chosen for this video
it's for a kind of an end of high school level or
people wanting to gain entrance into university.
Now this question was translated and the wording
was quite long but essentially it said that
we've got two photographs of the sunset. Now in
photograph one the sun appears as a semicircle,
this is the ocean down here, the sun and then the
clouds. Now the distance from the top of the sun
to the waterline is 3.9 centimeters as measured
on the photograph, then after some undefined
time later we have picture number two and the sun
has sunk a little bit down over the horizon and
now the distance from the top of the sun to the
water is only 0.3 centimeters as measured on here.
Now what we want to find is this question mark,
this mystery distance in here, which is how wide
the sun appears in our second photo. A key word
from the question is that this first image of
the sun is a semi-circle and a semi-circle
is always exactly half of the circle so that
vertical distance that we're given is indeed
the radius so let's draw our own semicircle.
On here we can mark what we know. If
the sun initially looks like this,
then after some time we just see the top of
it, the distance in here was that given by 0.3
and this total distance we knew was 3.9 which
means that if we take 0.3 off that the rest is
3.6. Our mystery distance is this line all the
way across here but since we've cut it in half,
if the whole thing were to be called x this here
would just be x over 2 and we can actually draw a
right angle triangle right in here. Since it's
a semi-circle and this distance was the radius
this line here is also the radius
of the circle so is also 3.9
and with that we have a right angle triangle
where we know the value of two of the sides
and we're trying to find the third side. For
that we're able to use the pythagoras theorem.
If this is our right angle triangle and one
of the shorter sides is 'a' the other shorter
side is 'b' and the hypotenuse is 'c' then
the pythagoras theorem says that 'a' squared
plus 'b' squared is equal to 'c' squared. For us
'a' is 3.6 our 'b' is x over 2 and our 'c' is 3.9.
These decimal numbers are a little bit messy but
it's not impossible to calculate these squares,
remember you don't have a calculator for this
question. We could go over to the margins and
write 3.6 times 3.6 we could do 6 times
6 is 36 carry the 3, 3 times 6 is 18,
19 20 21, add a zero here go on to the
next line three sixes are 18, carry the 1,
3 3's are 9 plus the 1 is 10, add these up we'll
get 6 9 2 1. Two digits past the decimal place in
here so our decimal point will go between the
2 and the 9 and the answer to that would be
12.96. Again in our little margin we could do the
same to find 3.9 squared we'd go 3.9 times 3.9, 9
times 9 is 81, 3 times 9 is 27 plus 8 will
give us 35. So our next line 3 times 9 is 27,
3 times 3 is 9, 10 11.
This one will add to give us
15.21
So we've got 12.96 plus x over
2 squared is equal to 15.21.
x over 2 squared is equal to,
subtract the 12.9 from both sides.
To mentally find the difference between
these two numbers I'd say well this is only
0.04 away from 13 and then 13 is 2.21 away from
this so in total the difference would be 2.25.
x over 2 squared is the same as x squared over 4.
Times both sides by 4 to get rid of this we
have x squared is equal to 9 and thankfully
9 is a pretty easy number to take the square
root of so I'm going to go with x is equal to
3 centimeters and so three will be
the answer to this length in here.
Now I'm sorry to say but we actually did it the
slightly tedious way there was something that we
could have noticed which would have made these
calculations redundant and the algebra a little
bit easier, perhaps, depending on how familiar you
are with Pythagorean triples. Pythagorean triples
are known sets of numbers that satisfy this 'a'
squared plus 'b' squared equals 'c' squared.
The smallest one is 3, 4 and 5. Let's take a
look at a little bit of a visual proof of that.
If I had a right angle triangle where one side is
of length 3, and the other side is of length 4,
then the length of the remaining
longest side will be 5 squares.
With the way that the light is projected up onto
my wall things up here look a little bit larger
than things down here but believe me I've tried to
make all these individual squares the same size.
Each of these objects represents the side
length squared so 3 squared is this square
that's 1 2 3 by 1 2 3 a total
of 9 little squares. 4 squared
is 16 so there'll be 16 little squares here and
5 squared is 25. Pythagoras' theorem is saying
that the size of this should be
the same as the sizes of these two
added together. Here's our five squared
and I'm going to go at it with my scissors.
From this I can cut out a 4x4 grid.
Now I've got the 4x4 but let's see if this
little remaining bit can be made into a 3x3.
And there we go we can see our 4 squared and our 3
squared popping out of that 5 squared with nothing
left over. The next smallest Pythagorean triple is
actually 5, 12 and 13 so when we were back at this
stage there is a chance that we could have noticed
that 36 is 3 times 12 and so 3.6 is 3 times 1.2
and 3.9 is 3 times 1.3 so following
our Pythagorean triple x over 2
would have to be equal to 0.5 times 3. That's
1.5 so x would be equal to, well multiply by 2,
that's 3 centimeters. A faster way to get the
same solution that we had before. I don't know if
you'll agree that it simplifies the math by much
but people have been using Pythagorean triples
to simplify their working for literally thousands
of years. We've seen Pythagorean triples used on
the world's oldest example of applied geometry
on a 3700 year old Babylonian clay tablet
which laid out the division of land and boundaries
of a field and used Pythagorean triples like 5,
12 and 13 a thousand years before Pythagoras
himself was even born. So Pythagoras wasn't the
first person to invent this or to find these
triples but the theorem still holds his name.
Our next stop is Australia, now this is an exam
question from what is called the HSC advanced
paper and that is something that would be sat by
high school students in the Australian state of
New South Wales. The question says calculate
the sum of the arithmetic series 4 plus
10 plus 16 plus dot dot plus 1354. An arithmetic
sequence is a sequence of numbers in which there
is a constant difference between each term so
you're adding a constant amount every time.
An arithmetic series is what it's called when you
add all of these terms together. In general if we
called the first term of our sequence a then
our second term would be a plus d where d is
our difference and this one up here it looks like
d would be equal to six. You've added six here and
then again here and so on. The third term of our
sequence would be a plus 2d then all the way up to
our last term which would be a plus, well how many
times have we added d, if this is the nth term at
the end and we started adding d from the second
term onwards then we would have added d n minus
one times. If you already know the formula to find
the sum of any arithmetic series then you might be
able to look at this and plug it straight into
that formula but we're actually going to derive
it. So how do you add up one of these things well
let's call the sum of our general series here
S of n, we're going to add up each term
starting with a, then a plus d, then a plus 2d,
all the way to adding a plus n minus 1 d. Now
what we can do is write out the series again
but this time in reverse. We start with
our last term, a plus n minus 1d, and then
our second to last term which would be a
plus n minus 2 d, then a plus n minus 3 d,
and finishing with our first term a.
You often see mathematicians try this technique
where they write out the series again but
backwards that's because it allows them to do
some kind of cool tricks. One is to add these two
series together, we add S of n to itself, doing
that we would get two S of n's. The first term
of that would be a plus a plus n minus 1 d. Well
what is that? a plus a is 2a plus n minus 1 d.
The next term is a plus d plus a plus n minus 2 d
and that might look pretty different but actually
what do we have? an a here and an a here, 2a, plus
well we have n minus 2 d plus an extra d that's
actually n minus 1 d and in fact every term in
here gives you that same result. I'm going to run
out of room on my transparency but a plus 2 d plus
a plus n minus three d is also equal to 2a plus n
minus one d and you can see it pretty obviously
with our last term too. So in total we have that
two times S of n is equal to this term 2a plus
n minus 1 d repeated for however many terms we
have so repeated n times. To get rid of the 2
and get us the expression just for one series
we can do n over 2 and we can simplify it just a
little bit more if we look back to our sequence.
The last term is always a plus n minus 1d and
we kind of see most of that in here although we
have an extra a and well a is always the first
term so this can also be written as n over 2,
a which is the first term, plus the
last term maybe we can call that l.
Now that is the derivation of what will always
be the sum of an arithmetic series so let's get
to working out our problem. We have what we've
derived just here and we know that, well there's
a constant difference of 6 between each of our
terms, so d for us is going to be equal to 6.
Our very first term a is equal to 4 and our very
last term l is equal to 1354. We don't however
know our value of n they haven't told us how
many terms there are so we can't jump straight
into using this one instead let's put what we
know into this formula here for our last term.
If 1354 is equal to 4 plus n minus 1 times 6 then
subtracting the 4 and dividing by 6 we have 1350
divided by 6 is equal to n minus 1 that will be
225. I think you might be allowed a calculator
for this exam, this is the Australian one.
Is equal to n minus 1 and so n is 1 plus this.
n is equal to 226. Now we have n and all that we
need to calculate the sum so S of n is equal to
226 over 2, the first term plus the last term,
well if we plug all this into the calculator we
end up with 153454 as our answer, well who would
have guessed that's what it is adding up all that.
This question reminds me of a little story that
goes around about the mathematician Carl Gauss,
he's known as perhaps one of the greatest
mathematicians and this is a story from
the time when he was at school. Apparently Gauss's
teacher wanted a bit of peace and quiet so he
asked the class to add up all the numbers between
one and a hundred. As the other students set about
adding it all up very slowly and carefully Gauss
almost immediately wrote down the correct answer
which was 5050. Gauss could perhaps see a
formula similar to this one and applied it
to the problem. He's said to have imagined
it as folding up these numbers in half and
then adding up the pairs such as 1 and 100
and 2 and 99 that would be 50 pairs of 101
giving the answer, or expressed as a formula
the first and last term times n divided by two.
Now this anecdote tends to make the other students
in the class sound pretty unintelligent as if they
would add up one plus two plus three and do
every single step in order but I challenge you
to imagine doing this for yourself even if you
knew nothing about math or sequences and series
and these formulas and tricks, as you go through
the numbers you can't help but see some patterns,
in fact, it almost seems difficult to do it in
the hardest way. Maybe you'd see that in adding
up the numbers between 10 and 19 you'd get the
same sum as adding up the numbers lower than that
just with an extra 10 sets of 10. So just because
you're not Gauss answering it in a few seconds
doesn't mean there aren't lots of
ways to solve a problem like this.
This next question is from India, now often when
I've spoken about Indian exams on my channel
before I've spoken about things like the JEE
which is a super specialized, engineering focused,
really difficult paper for university entrance
but this question here is from the CBSE exams
and in fact the standard mathematics exam
for grade 10. Now this isn't even the most
advanced paper we could have gone to grade
11 or 12 but I found that picking the grade
10 one brought it a little bit more in line with
some of the other problems I've picked and made
it a little bit easier you know for this video
where I don't want to stress you out too much.
So these CBSE exam papers from India
are more standard, sort of given to
everyone rather than just those people
who want to specialize in engineering
so let's have a look at the problem. It says
the value of k for which the system of equations
x plus y minus four equals zero and two x
plus k y equals three has no solution is what?
Equations like these represent straight
lines and when we're talking about solutions
of systems of equations like this we can imagine
where the straight lines might intersect so if
we have an x y axis like this then in the case
where, for example one line might go like this
the other might go like this, we have
one place where the lines intersect and
that would represent one solution. We also
refer to this situation as being consistent.
Let's try another possibility, if we have one line
and then another line exactly over the top of it
so that you can barely even tell them apart
well we're going to have infinite solutions
because since these lines are
perfectly over the top of each other,
there are infinitely many places where they meet.
The situation is also referred to as consistent.
And there's one last possibility to consider
and that is in the case where our two lines,
one here and one here, are parallel to each other.
They're like train tracks perfectly parallel and
they're never getting closer or further away
they're always staying the same distance apart.
In this case there will be no solutions. The
situation is referred to as inconsistent.
So in our question we're asked where
these two straight lines have no solution
so really we're asked how we can ensure that
these lines will be parallel. We often see
straight lines written in this format y equals
m x plus c, this is the slope intercept format
and here m represents the slope of the line and
c represents the y-intercept, so where it cuts
the y-axis. For two lines to be parallel they
would differ only in the y-intercept so they would
have the same gradient but just shifted up or down
by some different amount c. If c was the same and
the gradient was the same well they'd be on top
of each other. So one way to solve this is to
rearrange both these equations into this form
and see what you can do to make sure that m
is the same for both lines but that c is
different. But this is a question on an
Indian exam and they love to find tricks where
you can solve these questions almost instantly
sometimes that involves memorizing a lot of
seemingly random little formulas and equations
to solve these quickly and maybe in the extreme
time pressure of exams like this maybe even
rearranging it into this form is way too slow
so let's see where a shortcut might come from.
In general, for simultaneous equations
in this form a x plus b y is equal to c,
often we can solve the equation by adding
these two together and hopefully in a way that
cancels out one of our variables.
For example if a1 was 1 and a2 was
-1 then adding these two together would remove the
variable x and you would be able to solve for y.
If a1 and a2 or b1 and b2 aren't already the same
magnitude we can multiply them by some constant
to make sure that they are we just have to make
sure to multiply every term by that same constant.
For us our equations can be written
as x plus y is equal to four and two x
plus k y is equal to three. If we
multiply the entire top equation by
minus 2 then adding these together we would see
the x variables disappear. We would have minus 2x
minus 2y is equal to minus 8. That's all
fine because we did it to every single term
so it's the same equation adding these up we have
0x then k minus 2 y being equal to minus five.
Now we don't know what k is but that's the thing
we're trying to find. Let's have a think about it,
if k was any value except for two, this would look
like a normal equation we'd have something times
y is equal to minus five. We could find
that y is equal to minus five divided
by whatever this value is, that would
represent a consistent set of equations,
one where there is one solution. But what
if it gets weird what if k is equal to two?
We'd have two minus two that's zero. Zero
times y is still zero and we would end up with
zero is equal to minus five, that is if k is
equal to two. Now believe it or not this is
actually what we want, seeing something like zero
is equal to minus five well that is inconsistent,
there is no solution to this because well
think of it like this, what values of x and y
result in zero being equal to minus five?
Well none. There are no values of x and y
that ever make this true. This is inconsistent
in the truest sense of the word, so the answer
to the problem is actually k is equal to two. And
if you're an indian student studying for an exam
you probably already know a shortcut way to think
about this. It is to say that for no solutions
we want to ensure that the ratio a1 over a2 that's
these values here, we want to ensure that is equal
to the ratio of b1 over b2 basically means that
when you decide to multiply it by that constant
minus 2 that we cancel both our x's and our y's
because these ratios are equal to each other
but we do not want both those to be equal to the
ratio of the constants c1 over c2 that is the
shortcut way to find the answer to this problem.
So if they had also been equal to c1 over c2
well in that case the constants would have also
cancelled out and we would have been left with
zero is equal to zero that doesn't represent no
solutions in fact this is always true. Zero is
always equal to zero so if this is the ratio
between all the coefficients you actually get
infinite solutions. Now I also had
questions prepared here from the UK's GCSE
and from the American SAT exams but i'm looking
at my camera, it's been filming for a long time,
looking at my mic it's about to run out of
batteries and i'm starting to feel like maybe i've
done enough already so perhaps i'll save those
extra two questions for a part two or if anyone
enjoyed this video or made it to the end let
me know and i'll know to keep them for later.
Thanks so much for watching this video i know
it's been a little bit different it's been a
little bit of a risk for me to do. If you've been
listening to try and fall asleep then good night
and if you've been watching to relax or unwind
i hope that the rest of your day is positive and
not too stressful that you get some good stuff
done. Thanks as always to my Patreon supporters
for making my videos possible and a special shout
out to today's Patreon Cats of the Day who
are very astronomically named Pan and Tilt.